Hello world,
it's arrived and let me show you how
to learn deep learning in six weeks.
What's next?
Rocket Science in one week and this video
will explain the six week curriculum
I've created to help you learn
the art of deep learning.
The only prerequisite is knowing basic
python and by the end of this curriculum
you'll have a broad understanding of
some of the key technologies that make up
deep learning.
You might be thinking why deep learning
without machine learning machine
learning is a broad set of algorithms
use to derive insights from data sets.
Deep learning is a subset
of all of those algorithms,
specifically all the various types of
neural networks and when applied to
massive datasets and given
massive computing power,
these neural networks will outperform
all other models. Most of the time.
Deep learning is the hottest field in
AI right now and it's responsible for
everything from Google's latest duplex
assistant to Tesla's self driving cars to
robot companions.
You can get a job as a deep learning
engineer by browsing through listings like
angel list,
Hacker News and indeed.com and when
it comes to getting hired by these
employers,
usually what they're looking
for is experience building,
training and deploying deep learning
models for real life use cases.
I uploading one project every
week to your get hub profile.
You'll have built a substantial portfolio
to show perspective employers and some
of them can even be deployed to
Heroku to be usable as a web app.
So where do we begin? Deep learning
is built on mathematical principles.
It's all math really specifically.
It's linear Algebra,
probability theory,
Calculus and statistics.
These are sub fields of math that cover
an enormous breadth of topics each and
it's a little daunting to
try to tackle them all.
Ideally we could learn from a
source that teaches us the subjects,
but not all of them. Just the relevant
parts that apply to deep learning.
The deep learning book by
Google brain researcher,
Ian Goodfellow does a perfect job of that.
It's free and openly
available on deep learning.
book.org for the first week of this
curriculum read part one of this book.
It does an incredible job of diving into
specific subtopics in each subject that
are used consistently in deep learning
terms like a derivative and doc product
are explained in an easy to understand
way with ample explanation behind the
math notation that's used.
I've also included a cheat sheet for
math notation to help you understand what
the symbols mean. If
you don't, don't worry.
If you don't get how all of these concepts
are used in a neural network right
away.
Just get yourself familiar with the
ideas presented in the book first. No,
that a matrix is a group of numbers and
matrices can be modified in different
ways.
No,
that a distribution models
the probabilities of
different possible outcomes
occurring in an experiment.
Once you've read part one,
it's time to build your
first neural network.
Watch my build a neural network in four
minutes video on youtube to get started.
Then read Andrew Track's amazing blog
post called a neural network in 11 lines
of python.
Fire up your text editor and start
coding your neural network in Python.
You don't have to memorize it to,
you could even type it out line by line
as you watch my video or stare at the
finish code,
but the simple act of typing it out
will be beneficial to your memory.
Your network is simply a series of
operations that are applied to some input
data until it results in some output data.
Nothing really special about that,
but the real magic of these things as
a result of an optimization technique
called back propagation,
it's how a neural network learns
to improve its output over time.
It's a technique from calculus.
I have a great video on this called
backpropagation in five minutes.
Check that one out.
By the end of this week,
you should have a basic idea of how a
simple feed forward neural network works
backpropagation included.
Once you've mastered that,
everything else becomes easier.
Every other neural network is just some
variation of this and each variation
excels at a specific use case.
Speaking of variations,
let's move on to week two
convolutional networks.
There's a lot of different types
of data out there. Numbers, text,
video,
audio in different types of networks
can be used to learn from each of them.
While feedforward networks are great for
learning the mapping between numerical
input and output data,
convolutional networks are wellmade
for learning from image data sets.
If we think of an image as a group
of numbers each describing it's pixel
intensity value on an RGB scale,
then we can consider it a matrix and
this matrix can be input into a neural
network operated on and result in an
output which is a class probability.
Confidence were invented by
young macaroon's team over
two decades ago and are
still responsible for some of the state
of the art advances in computer vision
technology including driverless vehicles.
A great resource to learn about them is
the convolutional neural networks course
on Coursera taught by professor
Andrew Ng of Stanford University.
It dives into both the architecture and
application specific details in an easy
to understand way like
all neural networks,
confidence have lots of variations,
deep convolutional networks,
skip connection networks that can also
be used as building blocks for more
complicated models like
variational auto encoders,
so it's important to really understand
the details of how these work.
A good supplement to the
course is Andre Karpov.
These lecture notes on CNN,
a part of his cs two 31 and convolutional
neural networks for visual recognition
course.
He has some amazingly detailed technical
documentation covering how they worked.
I also have some detailed videos on CNN,
a linked to them as well.
Moving on to week three
we're current networks.
While feedforward nets are
great for numerical data
and confidence are great for
images were current networks
are great for sequential data.
Any kind of data where
time matters, audio, video,
since videos are a sequence of
image frames, stock price data,
recurrent networks are the
perfect network to use here.
Why you might ask normally neural networks
while training only use the next data
point as an input,
but recurrent networks take both the next
data point and the learned state value
from the previous time step as input to
this recurrence allows it to remember
data sequentially course on.
This is again on Coursera by
professor Ang called sequence models.
This will cover the variations
of recurrent networks
including long short term
memory and gated recurrent unit
neural networks. Additionally,
I have some great videos on this link to
those will be in the provided syllabus
at the end of this week.
Make sure to write out a simple or
current network using Andrew tracks,
Lstm RNN python blog post as a guide.
Now that we have the basic types
of neural networks out of the way,
we can dive into some of the tooling
before it will be all about getting
yourself familiar with some
of the tools in this space.
And because up to this point,
you've only built your
neural networks using num Pi.
You'll appreciate the benefits of using
libraries like tensorflow and care
office rather than typing
out grading updates by hand.
You can benefit from TensorFlow's
automatic differentiation. For example,
of all the deep learning libraries,
I'd found tensorflow to be the best
tool to use since it offers a complete
pipeline for AI development
including building testing,
training and serving models in production.
A great course on this is
cs 20 by Stanford called
tensorflow for deep learning
research. You can find all
of those videos on Youtube.
I also have an awesome
playlist on tensorflow on my
channel that I'll link too.
If you can understand tensorflow, it's
computation graph, the basic operators,
how models are saved and how to serve
them in you will be unstoppable.
US is just a wrapper on top of tensorflow
that makes it even easier to write
models.
Read the documentation page examples to
quickly get an understanding of how it
works.
You also want to read this blog post
that compares some of the Best Gpu cloud
providers so you get a sense of their
pros and cons and can decide on which one
is the best one for you to use.
At the end of this week,
you should write out a simple image
classification demo using tensorflow as
practice.
Once we've got that down in week five we
can peer into one of the newest models
in deep learning,
the generative adversarial network.
This allows us to generate all sorts of
data and it's currently very popular.
We can learn about these
models from youtube.
I've got some great videos on gans.
You can also find some
interesting lectures on gains
that I've compiled in the
syllabus by researchers across the field
and explore their possibilities across
a wide range of applications
and two projects for this week.
Build again from scratch and build again.
Using tensorflow for the last week,
we can focus on the most
bleeding edge of all techniques,
deep reinforcement learning.
This is what's responsible for some of
the latest breakthroughs in the field,
including Alphago, the
Atari DPQ learner, and more.
Berkeley recently released a free course
called cs two 94 deep reinforcement
learning.
You can find all the videos on youtube
or reddit community of students and a
bunch of help or materials
on their website.
This one is nontrivial and it could even
take you two weeks to finish this bit.
Reinforcement learning is different from
supervised and unsupervised learning.
While these either try to learn a
mapping or cluster similar data points
together,
our El tries to learn by trial and error
and some kind of environment where time
is a dementia,
not just a static data set.
It's very likely that the brain learns
using some combination of our l and other
types of learning,
which could be why deep RL,
a combination of learning styles
has gotten such incredible results.
For a final project, create a deep cute
learning algorithm using tensorflow.
You can have it playing Atari Games
using the open AI gym environment.
Deep learning is the dark art of our time,
extremely powerful and mysteriously
good at everything we throw at it,
followed the curriculum I've created.
Find a study buddy to help you stick to
it and post your experiences in the slot
channel. Good luck. Welcome
to the end of the video.
If your model is not converging, hit the
subscribe button and it will for now.
I'll get to learn deep learning again,
so thanks for watching.